I added fields to my Set Time object.
>> Great.
>> I added the tab so I can see it here, and I have
clicked in, and I am ready. I'm
going to start entering some records. Sound good?
>> Sounds good.
>> Alright. What time shall our first band play at?
Oh, I mean what stage should our first band play at?
>>
[LAUGH]
let's put it at the Udacity stage. And I know that I can go
into the page layout thing and add those other fields if I wanted but.
>> Right.
>> Not.
>> Yup.
>> Too concerned right now. Okay. And, what band should be playing?
>> Search for something. See if they what
about code? There's gotta be a code band.
>> Code Against the Machines, what about that?
>> Code Against the Machines for sure
[LAUGH].
Right and save. So this is our set time record.
>> Right
>> For code against the machine, playing the Udacity stage.
>> Right. So we can see how it links to both the stage and the band.
>> Okay, so let's see what happens if I actually click on Udacity
stage. So this is the stage record, and yeah it's not showing me
any of the bands that are playing here. Which is unfortunately, because I
would love it to. It feels like it should be showing me that.
>> So it should be
showing you that, and it could be showing you
that. How do you think you could add it there?